こんにちは　はじめs...
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
ただいま時刻朝の
☆GO☆JI☆
最近復活したアバンティーズの新しい 家
さすがの朝5時になるとみんな寝てるんすよねぇ今
はいというわけで今
この部屋にはアバンティーズ
うるさい！
というわけで今この部屋には
ちょぉ！
アバンティーズ全員４人いるんですけどもぉ
昔１回ねぇスコラッチィ（？）がそらちぃが寝てる時に話しかけると
彼はもう浅い睡眠状態　もうノンレム睡眠
こっちの世界にもう意識はない状態なのに話しかけると
ちゃんと返答してくれる...んですけど
その返答がすごい面白かったっていう過去の例があったったので
ひょっとしたら他のメンバーも寝てる時面白いんじゃないかっていう僕の予想のもと
睡眠状態に陥っている彼らが果たして
話しかけることによってどう反応してくれるのか
試していきたいと思います
ではいこう
エイちゃん？
はいはい
こんにちは
うん
（神々しい音楽）
次はリクヲ君ですね
さあどんどん行きましょう
僕ももう寝たいからなぁ
パッと済ませたいところではある
リクヲ？
おはよう
え？
なんて？
※レジスタンス・・・抵抗、反抗、（物理的な）抵抗、耐性、抵抗運動
ちゃんと布団かけて寝ないとダメでしょ
フフフww
んぅ
チョコか
www
ありがとうリクヲ
おやすみ
おやすみい
残るメンバーはあと２人！
さすがですね　寝ていてもしっかりYouTuberということを忘れない
常にボケ続けてます彼らは
アバンティーズのかなめといっても間違いのない存在
ツリメ君です
こんにちは
ツリメ？
デーーーーン
www
ツリメ
おはよう
！？
ﾋﾞﾖﾝ
おはよう
おはよー
彼は深い眠りにつき..........
返事をすることがなかったが
その右腕は
はっきりと彼の意思表示をしていた
ぅうわってぇぇぇぇん
はい　というわけで
アバンティーズ全員見ていったわけなんですけども
広いねホント
んぅ広いんすよ意外と
極めて広いね
お風呂はいりたいな
謎...！？
謎？
ｳﾞｳﾞｳﾞ
んｳﾞｧｧ
ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑ﾍﾟ↓ﾍﾟ↑
Ｑ：パンはパンでも食べられないパンは？
Ａ：悲しい
www
悲しいって言った？今w
Ｑ：パンはパンでも食べられないパンは？
Ａ：悲しい
www
悲しいってw？